[Música]
y seguimos hablando por supuesto de este
tema porque un centenar de salvas de
cañón en londres marcaron el 96
cumpleaños de la reina isabel segunda
este año el festejo va a coincidir con
las celebraciones y actividades
organizadas para el jubileo de platino
que son los 70 años del reinado de
isabel segunda que llegó al trono tras
la muerte de su padre jorge sexto el
pasado 6 de febrero de 1952 2021 y 2022
han sido años complicados para la reina
por la muerte de su esposo el príncipe
felipe la demanda de abuso sexual contra
su hijo andrés y también sus crecientes
problemas de salud motivo de
preocupación desde que los médicos la
obligaron a guardar reposo y también
contrajo el virus del sars co2 el coi 19
para ello para hablar de la reina lo que
está pasando las consecuencias de lo que
ha sido su reinado y pues un balance
completo por supuesto quiere saludar a
que menos si no en angola no miembro de
la asociación de amigos de castillo de
windsor armas no billaristas experto en
temas de la monarquía hernán gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa muchas gracias por la invitación
el rand hagamos entonces
el avance de lo que ha sido estos años
de vida 96 años de vida de la reina
isabel segunda de más 70 en el trono si
precisamente una princesa como nació
como princesa de york hasta que su padre
entonces es
designado rey por la abdicación de su
tío ella a los 26 años recibe la noticia
de la muerte de su padre estando en
tanzania y desde allí pues se ha marcado
una nueva era isabelina la segunda
isabel es ella después de la isabel del
siglo 16 la cuarta mujer en ocupar ese
trono después de maría isabel su
tatarabuela victoria y ella que en 70
años pues también ha sido protagonista
no sólo del protocolo de las buenas
maneras de trascender entre otros por
ejemplo a 13 presidentes de los eeuu
sólo uno no lo que no la conoció que fue
lyndon johnson
a una vida larga que seguramente
trascenderá de los 100 años porque la
mamá de ella la sabe la reina madre
vivió 101 años 99 años su esposo
entonces tenemos allí de todas maneras
los genes por el lado de la emperatriz
victoria porque su esposo era el tío de
ella en tercer grado y primo en cuarto
grado
por el lado battenberg aunque él adoptó
el apellido mumbat en el apellido de su
familia materna inglesa cuando contrajo
nupcias con isabel porque antes era
felipe de grecia y dinamarca de esa
manera entonces surge una familia que ha
dado también para muchos escándalos
carlos
anna andrés eduardo todos ellos con
historias distintas y como lo decías
ahora precisamente 2021-2022 fue el
segundo annus horribilis año terrible
como ella calificó también a 1997 cuando
se incendió el castillo de windsor
cuando murió diana de gales cuando se
divorciaron un poco antes también carlos
y andrés de sus esposas ahora como como
lo decíamos hernán han sido años
difíciles la muerte del esposo el
escándalo del príncipe andrés y también
su estado de salud que pues últimamente
no ha estado como también que digamos
aunque ahorita está ya digamos entre
comillas a perfecta en estos años
difíciles como han afectado en la
monarquía y como afectados sobre todo
la vida emocional la salud mental de la
reina isabel bueno la afectaba mucho
precisamente el que uno de sus doce
nietos el el príncipe harry pues ha
tenido que separarlo ella también de las
labores
pues nunca la fue muy bien con la esposa
de él
de hecho lilibeth la hija de harry no la
conoce que ya tiene diez meses no la
conoce isabel a otras dos de sus ocho
bisnietos y las bautizaron recientemente
en presencia de la reina en sant griñán
y la salud mental de la reina pues de es
de todas maneras de la tristeza del
enamoramiento porque ya desde los 13
años se enamoró de felipe se casó con él
a los 26 y vivir pues pendiente de una
persona casi 80 años pues ha sido muy
duro para ella adicionalmente se
contagió de kobe se dice que el coi la
dejo extenuada y últimamente pues
también ha tenido bastantes problemas de
movilidad que le han hecho ya hacer uso
de un bastón cuando ella aunque fuera
con un paso más lento siempre caminaba
firme y así había manejado las riendas
del reino el principio dentro leemos de
ese escándalo que también la afectaba
muchísimo se ha dicho usted obviamente
conoce más la vida de la reina y lo que
podría estar pasando en el en el
castillo y en el y en el palacio esto
realmente ha habilitado la monarquía
si es un escándalo complicado por el
pago de la indemnización para evitar la
acusación y adicionalmente la reina de
todas maneras hace lo que quiere porque
recientemente con ocasión de los oficios
por el aniversario del primer año de
fallecimiento del príncipe felipe fue
andrés como príncipe aunque le separaron
el título de duque de york quien la
llevó del brazo por la abadía de
westminster para el servicio religioso
esto pues no no cayó muy bien al igual
que para otras personas tampoco ha caído
muy bien que en el mensaje inicial de
este año 2022 dijo cuando mi hijo sea
rey espero que le den a camila todo el
tratamiento y toda la consideración del
caso como reina consorte esta semana
precisamente ha emitido un comunicado
designando a camila para representarla
en los actos presenciales aunque la
reina es patrona de más de 600
fundaciones y asociaciones
muchas de esas asociaciones no se
reunían hace tiempo y ahora han contado
con la presencia virtual de la lo cual
ha permitido de esa manera que ella
también se haga partícipe de muchos
eventos pero para los particulares ha
delegado a su nuera usted no está acá
ahorita qué va a pasar con la reina
digamos tiene pensado a lo mejor aplicar
o va a estar en el trono en sus últimos
días y también qué va a pasar con los
hijos del príncipe carlos el príncipe
william no tiene la posibilidad de ser
rey sino su padre pues realmente la
reina madre isabel como lo comentaba
murió de 101 años probablemente la reina
con todos los achaques de salud que esté
hasta el último momento porque haya sido
firme en cuanto al juramento que en 1952
hizo como reina y como defensora de la
fe que es un título además que se le dio
a enrique octavo y con el cual se
aprovechó en su momento para el cisma
anglicano en el caso de carlos que ya
tiene 74 años próximamente pues
probablemente el de él sí sea un reinado
de transición ya el príncipe william de
40 años que cumple este año pues está
digamos maduro para el trono ha asumido
con mucha responsabilidad no ha dado un
costado paso al costado sino un paso al
frente para respaldar a la reina lo
mismo que la duquesa de cambridge
catalina quien también cumple 40 años
este año y los tres hijos que son la
esperanza del sostenimiento como tal de
una institución de monarquía inglesa que
aparece en el año 1066 con guillermo el
conquistador o guillermo de normandía
como esta la estabilidad y la
durabilidad de esta corona británica de
tantos años de antigüedad hasta el
momento tradicionalmente con la
formación que recibían bueno la reina se
formó por institutriz es en la propia
casa pero tanto el príncipe carlos como
el príncipe william se formaron en el it
on college
entonces pues tiene cierta estabilidad
no sabemos los tres hijos de los duques
de cambridge que piensen en el futuro
sobre la monarquía están muy pequeños
tal vez los están formando para el tema
pero la reina también ha sido
protagonista de transformación en
inglaterra no solo la segunda guerra
mundial sino entre otras hasta el
nacimiento del rock cuando en 1965 tuvo
que condecorará los beatles quienes
confesaron posteriormente que se reían
tanto durante la ceremonia la cual los
condecoraron porque se habían formado
unos porros de marihuana en los baños
del palacio de botica porque ha sido tan
quería a la reina cual lo mejor ha sido
su secreto el secreto de la reina es
mano de hierro con sus guantes de
cabritilla pero también el secreto de la
reina para durar tanto ha sido el que en
las noches no se acuesta sin tomarse
una ginebra ah bueno vamos a tener que
usar ese secreto de larráun que le gusta
mucho el dúo net le gusta entonces a
veces de tomarse algunos o coctelitos
pero como va a ser hablando de
celebraciones y de tragos estos 70 años
de la reina en el trono precisamente
todos los territorios vinculados a la
corona que son 54 y los estados que
hacen parte de la mancomunidad británica
dentro d e incluso por ejemplo australia
o canadá de los cuales es reina de
acuerdo con la constitución como jefa
del estado tienen preparados diferentes
eventos para conmemorar esos 70 años en
el trono en los los días al comienzo
precisamente los cañonazos desde los
diferentes palacios ella ya no volvió a
londres desde la pandemia vive en
windsor ahora está en su otra residencia
pero seguramente unido a celebraciones
litúrgicas siendo a la cabeza de la
iglesia anglicana
celebraciones en todas estas
asociaciones de las cuales es patrona y
igualmente en todos los territorios será
motivo de celebración porque aunque haya
habido escándalos aunque incluso haya
habido también dudas acerca de la
fidelidad del príncipe felipe la reina
ha sido símbolo de la unidad de los
ingleses en estos años y particularmente
eso se le debe también a la reina madre
porque la reina madre tomó un papel
fundamental durante la segunda guerra
mundial con sus niñas
evitando la recomendación del lord
canciller de que las niñas se fueran es
decir margarita e isabel se fueran a
vivir a canadá porque ella dijo yo no
dejo ir a mis niñas solas y yo no voy a
abandonar el rey entonces se quedaron
allí y fueron motivo fundamental como de
un papel propagandístico hacia la unidad
de los ingleses para combatir a los
alemanes en la segunda guerra mundial
tanto así que adolfo hitler calificó a
la reina madre como la mujer más
peligrosa de europa rápidamente 30
segundos tenemos reina para rato sí por
lo menos para cuatro años más para
llegar a la edad de su madre